sanding is with a sendees in Los Angeles
hi Sandy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave all right thanks for taking my
call sure I think I believe in wealth
the Equality of wealth being spread
evenly among amongst us all one how now
how we get there in the methods I think
is what people are upset about you know
lobbying groups can go in and Lobby your
Congressman you know big big
corporations so that Exxon gets a tax
refund rather than to pay taxes why we
subsidize the oil industry when you know
subsidies are good for start-up
companies but obviously we know that
these companies are up and running and
well I mean we're talking about
individual wealth here Exxon's wealth um
well it and so I think you you think
that everybody's wealth ought to be
distributed equally well I think the
method in which when people don't
understand go back to that answer the
question do you think that do you do you
think you said earlier I think well
should be distributed equally well I
think yes
you know now again how we get there is
why a different why shall be distributed
equally well because well it's see
that's what I'm saying the method in
which we get there I think if method
ever comes out of the why why do you
believe it should be distributed equally
because I think it makes for a better
society you know I think so much of a
spread if you have the robber barons and
Koch brothers in today's you know
today's era you know you think it makes
a better society for everyone regardless
of the effort or talent that they have
to make the same amount of money and
keep the same way.not money it's not
going to make society perfect but it it
makes it more tolerable it makes it
where people aren't unruly because they
feel hey they're getting the better of
us have your laurette have you ever read
Karl Marx Karl Marx no no I'm not a
communist in III Arn
by definition you are now it's not
name-calling you truly believe in there
even though
tribution of wealth it's not
name-calling you believe in autism it's
exactly what you just outlined with all
due respect Dave I think people want to
go back to the way the system worked in
the 40s right after World War two you
know with the the brothers the Roosevelt
era you know the new society and I think
people in the long run start seeing that
Republicans and some Democrats you know
they're starting to tear down those
opportunities that were once advanced oh
what what what opportunity is not
available to some women
if opportunities are available what does
it matter if everyone ends up with the
same why would I care well the
opportunity has to be there you can't
let a company equal opportunity I'm okay
with but equal distribution is where you
and I would Park company but but you
know what opportunities are not
available that were available in the 40s
well an opportunity that a high school
graduate could go and work at a factory
and carve out a good living you know a
nice living just like my parents or my
grandparents did so you don't think the
high school graduate can make it in
today's society it's a little more
tougher because the companies aren't
there anymore the factories aren't there
you know and when they are there they
want to just pay you just be thankful
you get minimum wage I mean come on if
you ever visited than any of the Nissan
plants or any of the new core plants
that I visited there are steel workers
in in corn fields in Kansas making a
hundred thousand dollars a year working
in new core factories okay but I think
that's the rare I mean that you know how
many companies are there like that I
think there's a whole lot more than
maybe you realize that's my point I
think I think you're believing a
party-line or a talking point that
you've not really backed up with
actually she died I came out of the
church at you know I was a Christian you
know and and I am a Christian I bill so
I wrote it Republican because I that
that was a you know the drone that would
beat all the Republicans are the
Christians I got to do
with what I just said well because now
you're trying to label me that you think
you know I I'm a certain party I'm not
and I said you running for that's not a
party I said you know you don't you you
believe a party line of a party line a
talking point regardless of a political
party but you believe a talking point
that there are no places for a
high-school graduate to go when in
America today and yet I didn't percent
there's none but there aren't any
percent of the current generations
millionaires are first-generation rich
well in and that's the other thing you
know Henry Ford went bankrupt seventeen
times before he made it big from teen
times where did you get that information
I don't get all look it up online
seventeen times making up some of it is
going to be true in some of its
seventeen times 17 times is what my
understanding from what I've read yeah
you know and I don't think he would have
been doing anything his entire life
except going to bankruptcy court had he
filed so many but that was what
bankruptcy was for and you know yourself
it was it was to get a fresh start so
that the creditor still didn't have a
strong hold on you so you think
bankruptcy is an amendment that or used
to build wealth what that I'm so your
implication is is that bankruptcies the
method that Ford Henry Ford used to
build wealth no it gave them the
opportunity to start over upon saying
and now you do that now well bankruptcy
and try to start over again because uh
if you make a certain amount of money
then you're going to hold you to
payments so you should the difference
you know that's all I'm saying is the
loop I mean the the lobbyists for credit
card companies four-bit Corp have
allowed the lobbyists to make these gone
into these congressmen to allow these
laws and that's the feed people feel
that the odds are stacked against us and
so you back to your original statement
and to make sure I have this correct
you believe that wealth should be
distributed equally and you think the
devil is in the details the problem is
where all the problems come up is how to
do that correct because let
let me tell you or let me tell you one
of the problems for you to consider on
an intellectual level once it was
distributed equally talent good looks
energy and discipline is not distributed
equally and so once it's distributed
equally it won't remain equal right
that's the problem but at least give
people the same opportunities and that's
where people are they are getting
frustrated that's where I think because
we've been telling them they don't have
the opportunity and they started to
believe it instead of saying this is the
land of opportunity where you have the
right to pursue happiness and it's the
greatest country the world has ever
known instead we're running around going
hey look how rich that guy is and you'll
never get there because the game is
fixed and that's that's when we stole
their opportunity because we stole their
hope with this fatalism right and so we
need to address those questions that's
all I'm saying that's what I'm saying so
don't have don't let Exxon don't quit
subsidizing big companies quit
subsidizing these people that people
this organization that organization I
don't disagree with you I don't disagree
with you let me give you an example of
what's interesting on that the very jobs
that you were wanting someone to have at
a factory don't usually come if that
factory ends up in your neighborhood the
reason ends up in your neighborhood is
if that municipality gives that company
a tax break to come to your neighborhood
now you shouldn't be because Walmart is
the biggest offender of that thing but
here's the problem though if you don't
give them the tax break to come your
neighborhood those jobs aren't there and
they go to Mexico that's not true that's
not true we're gonna go to another
neighborhood what do you think what's
what do you think plants decide to build
they go where there's tax breaks it does
that make it right no it doesn't make it
right just because South Dakota gives
all the credit card companies carte
blanche to do whatever they want and and
and let's say Indiana won't you know so
everybody goes and runs to South Dakota
that's not right yeah but in some of
those jobs aren't those jobs aren't in
Indiana those people that we're worried
about having jobs an opportunity earlier
you took their opportunity way because
you're worried about subsidizing that
company I'm not sure I agree with
subsidizing these companies but that's
the that's the that's the paradox of it
is if you want a wonderful big fabulous
company to come to your neighborhood
your neighborhoods going to get my tax
break and that's where those jobs come
from it's called economic development
and it's a paradox I agree with you on
that part I don't agree with you on
hardly anything else though and you do
need to go read Karl Marx honestly you
really need a grass book because it
aligns with your philosophy and again
that's not name-calling it's just you
need to grasp what what school of
thought that you've been sold and bought
into because it's so desperately wrong
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you